ó sonho gol
[Música]
e aí galera que assistiu o planalto você
está tudo bom e tanque bom comigo também
não está porque ele sabe que jogo sendo
aquele jogo que causou discórdia no
mundo e satanás mais nova cara foi um
jogo chato nardi se vai te proteger arte
e fazem raiva diz aos outros tipos pois
é tá nice é aquele jogo não satisfeito
lançar um jogo chamado mim cutters meu
pai é é um flashback era um jogo difícil
o jogo mais difícil do mundo causa do
tempo ruim ninguém consegue passar eu
fiz 252 pontos
chama tomar agora chama de tomar em
cadeia chama chama tomar água pois é
queridos neste jogo novo novo jogo de
satanás meu recorde
2.2 pontos 2 não é 3 não é 41 f2 no
tempo certo
2.2 por esse jogo é um negócio de ficar
apertando o ópera felipe o outro começa
se a pele vai puxar a pele vai porque
você tem que desviar você tem que
desviar desse negócio ao autor
gente o que é esse bichinho não tô
ligado no que é parece uma assim uma
batata 1
[Música]
se você reparar bem parece um ovo mas
não houve de galinha o meu pai meu ovo
vai filha da [ __ ]
se você tem esse jogo no seu celular
está jogando no meu ombro está o jogo do
sábado escape o outro
é aí só quero três só quero três bolas o
abraço painéis
ai meu deus eu te odeio o ovo do inferno
eu tenho estou me sentindo um idiota
também foi total
também não não joga mais aquele jogo não
não gosto não rodei rodei aquele jogo
também não estou jogando mais
meu deus meu deus meu deus eu fiz três
meu deus eu fiz três meu deus não me
recorde new neu agradecer meu pai minha
mãe minha promessa da terceira série que
me ajudou foi um filho nunca desiste ao
emmy seguir que diz sonhar nunca desisti
e tefé no espeto de madeira sabe porque
galé porque quem vai a romã se olha os
dentes pp madeira no cavalo de pau mas
vai um cavalo o voando que 12 jogadores
na casa do pedreiro vamos nessa pra
quebrar o recorde agora pai agora é 4
a meta é 4 abalou o pastor é o índice
precisa de oração tempo passar por uma
aprovação não conseguir a tripulação do
sacanagem porque a chuva me ajuda
bora o idiota eu odeio o mundo
vou cantar vai vai é a musa do axé não
tá pode ser que seja a música vamos
tratar de música é essa equipe é a musa
do verão calor no coração
meu deus meu deus quando o [ __ ]
caraca moleque de e 44
a meta agora é sim
deu certo a música vão continuar com a
música é a pj de ontem agora vai essa
desgraça e nutricional e cai aqui num
[Música]
audi ottawa que eu vou fazer eu vou dar
pressão nem estou certo e ciente da
pressão eu xingar esse risco tanto é que
ele vai passar por ele me quer ver com a
questão é quem jogue seu babaca sobem
silva e dj batata tivesse outro não mac
box que quer não vou buscar fazer batata
frita de tudo jorge rech de aborto não
foi interrompido é errado o país goza
hospedar tua mãe só que não deu tempo
seu babaca idiota batata tem perfil do
fatah na oferta que black para o ano
passado 4 pra mim é esse o barra em são
jorge eu vou direto na eu vou direto na
casa eu vou telefonar para ver se agora
vai
só assim pode matar ninguém olha olha o
meu deus meu deus meu deus meu tenho
cinco meu deus é rico e costa
agora é o 8 o ataque é mais fácil se
dessa vez eu não quebrar o recorde
eu vou dar um tiro no pé
ae gilsinho
ai meu deus cara a cara
não quero mais última vez na última vez
meu deus meu deus meu deus sede e não
nosso não vou passar eu fiz é que eu
consigo 10
8 vila é 10 k é 10 agora também não cai
mas também no cairo jon leyne o chutei a
gol de di galera por favor clique no
botão teve medo do meu deus por favor
não chegou esse jogo que você comente
aqui embaixo é a pontuação você finge
que vai você comente aqui em baixo foi o
jogo mais difícil da sua vida mesmo que
seja um jogo da cobrinha tetris tanto
faz show em aracaju foi muito mas
ninguém presente para gastar e pelo modo
a vocês e dia 14 agora você tem dia 14
votar em são luís no ael 14 de setembro
votar em são luís no dia 20 de setembro
votarem sobra anunciará no dia 26 de
setembro votar em brasília e no dia 28
em fortaleza para comprar o ingresso
para saber sobre o show saber que ora é
saber que o lugar que vai ser tudo aqui
na descrição do vídeo cada show que na
descrição do vídeo tem música tem piada
tem tudo se você ficou curioso sobre a
arma atira essas bolinhas aqui ó
dói faz graça e onde queria sair daqui
na tática o sport sai aracaju fica na
avenida augusto maynard número 151 no
bairro são josé
é a primeira vez que assisti a um vídeo
meu técnico não gostei escreve se no
canal a toda vez que tiver um milhão sem
saber agora o curso gostei é do é aqui
na barriga já de gostei tenta se matar
gostei bastante clique todo dia música
de graça no entanto enfim obrigado eu
estiver aqui é nós agora vamos jogar
essa desgraça tel passar esse cão beijo
no fígado
até mais